مركبه جيد رابت التابعه للصين بدات مهمتها
باكتشاف القمر المركبه انفصلت عن مسبار
قمري اكبر في الساعات الاولى لصباح الاحد
والمسبار حط بهبوط تاريخي على القمر ما
يجعل الصين ثالث دوله في العالم تنجح في
تحقيق هذا الانجاز العلمي بعد الولايات
المتحده
وروسيا شاهدا لعلماء وكاله الفضاء الصينيه
وهم يحتفلون بهذا الانجاز في اللحظات التي
هبط فيها المسبار بنجاح على القمر احد
اهداف المركبه التي تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه
بشكل جزئي هو اكتشاف منطقه في القمر تعرف
بسنس اريديوم او خليج الطيف كما انها كلفت
بفحص الطبقه التي تقبع تحت سطح القمر
باستخدام جهاز رصد يخترق الاسطح للبحث عن
رواسب معدنيه بعض الخبراء قالوا لشبكتنا
ان من المحتمل ان تكون الصين تبحث
احتمالات التنقيب على القمر في المستقبل
الصينيون اعترفوا بان برنامجهم الفضائي لا
يزال متاخرا بعقود مقارنه بامريكا وروسيا
لكن يبدو ان هذه الخطوه هو جزء من
استراتيجيه اشمل تتضمن انشاء نظامها الخاص
من الاقمار الصناعيه لتحديد المواقع اضافه
الى بناء محطه ماهوله خاصه بها في الضاء
لانه اذا سارت الامور كما هو مخطط له
عندما يتم الاستغناء عن محطه الفضاء
الدوليه في عام 2020 فان الصين ستكون
الدوله الوحيده التي تملك محطه فضاء
ماهوله تدور حول
الارض